The new Wednesday Addams series is a huge hit
and loaded with kooky and spooky easter eggs
to the 90s movies and original sitcom!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan
and I've been re-watching and pausing
Wednesday to uncover all the weirdest
little details you might have missed!
The series begins with Wednesday going to
regular school where she finds her brother Pugsley
trussed up with an apple stuffed in his mouth,
mirroring how he was introduced in the 1991
Addams Family movie where Wednesday had him
tied up for archery practice.
Tim Burton directs the new series
and there are numerous references
to his movies throughout the show.
If you stop and zoom in on Principal
Weem's desk, there's a little dried-up
head under a glass dome, a nod to Harry The
Hunter's shrunken head from Beetlejuice.
And the giant bear in the Principal's office
is a call-back to the enormous stuffed bear in
the Addams family home from the 60s TV show.
When Wednesday ends up in the infirmary after
the gargoyle incident, she lies
in the bed with her arms crossed
– as if she were in a coffin
– which is also how she went
to sleep in the first movie.
After Wednesday meets Tyler for the
first time, she explains she knows how to fix
his broken coffee machine as she has a device
with a similar mechanism at home.
Steam-powered guillotine.
I built it when I was ten.
I wanted to decapitate my dolls more efficiently.
This is a throwback to the guillotine scene
in Addams Family Values where Wednesday and
Pugsley attempt to re-enact the beheading
of Marie Antoinette on their baby brother.
Death to the enemies of the
people of the Republic.
And Wednesday's mention of decapitating her dolls
is a nod to both the sitcom where she had a doll
with a severed head and also the 90s movie.
The show tips its hat to the classic Addams
Family theme tune from the 60s show in the
first episode when Tyler tells Wednesday…
You're not scary.
You're just kinda…
kooky.
And she replies…
I prefer spooky…
The clue to unlocking the secret entrance to the
Nightshade Society's basement is to "snap twice"…
[snaps twice]
another easter egg to the theme
tune from the original sitcom.
Wednesday's dancing at the Nevermore Rave'N
has already become a much-loved moment,
with Jenna Ortega revealing that she
choreographed the whole routine herself!
She also confirmed my suspicions that some of her
moves were a homage to the dance performed by Lisa
Loring in the original sitcom, where "she does [a]
side shuffle with her hands and with her feet."
Then if you learn how to dance
well, she'll think you're boss.
"Boss"?
Neat...
Groovy...
Ortega also said she took some inspiration
from "The Rich Man's Frug" dance craze that
featured in Bob Fosse's musical Sweet Charity.
Later at the dance, Lucas and his mates drench
everyone with red paint, in a nod to Stephen
King's Carrie where a group of mean girls
shower Carrie with a bucket of pig's blood,
something that Wednesday herself references.
They couldn't even spring for real pigs blood.
It's only paint.
When Xavier asks Wednesday if she's
ever shot a bow and arrow, she replies…
Only on live targets.
Which is a call-back to Addams Family Values when
Wednesday and Pugsley were lining up for archery
practice and her brother shot down a live bird.
It's an American bald eagle!
But aren't they extinct?
They are now.
Among the many taxidermied mice and
animals at Uriah's Heap, there are
several easter eggs to Tim Burton's films.
I spotted this one of a dead rodent in a
wedding dress, a reference to Corpse Bride.
I also saw this Freddy Krueger creature with
the Nightmare on Elm Street villain's iconic
red-striped top, fedora, and blades for hands.
Like Freddie Krueger who infiltrates and attacks
his victims in their dreams, the Hyde also
attacked Xavier during one of his visions.
This creature's been haunting my
dreams for the past couple of weeks.
When I was painting this one, the claws reached
out of the canvas and took a swipe at me.
That's how I got these scratches.
It's Dr Kinbott who creates the dressed-up
taxidermy rodents, and among the many she has
at home is one that's dressed as Beetlejuice.
Plus there's another Freddie Krueger
one as well.
When Wednesday goes to
find Tyler at the Weathervane, she rings
a bell and after he comes out he says
[bell dings]
You rang?
This is a nod to the Addams Family servant Lurch,
and the recurring gag where the family would ring
an enormous gong to summon him.
You rang?
Yes, Lurch.
And when Tyler wonders whether
Wednesday was ever a girl scout, she replies…
I can eat Girl Scouts for breakfast.
This is a funny reference to the Addams
Family movie and Wednesday's reaction when
Amanda asked if she or Pugsley wanted
to buy any of her Girl Scout cookies.
I'll buy a cup if you buy a box of
my delicious Girl Scout cookies.
Do we have a deal?
Are they made from real Girl Scouts?
When Wednesday breaks into the old meeting
house, she comes across an old painting of
Crackstone and notices a woman on
the left looking out towards her.
When the camera cuts in for a close-up, it
appears to be Goody Addams, Wednesday's ancestor.
However, if you compare this with the
woman in the wide shot of the painting,
they aren't the same person.
I can't be sure this isn't a
continuity error, but I suspect it could well
be a deliberate decision to give the sense that
the painting is alive, or that Goody's ghost
is communicating through it to Wednesday.
After Wednesday discovers the
truth about Crackstone's evil past,
she and Thing conspire to burn down
the statue of the evil pilgrim.
And this feels a lot like a nod to Addams
Family Values where Wednesday instigated
a revolt against the camp, and her
gang burned down the pilgrim set.
I have decided to scalp you and
burn your village to the ground
By the way, when Crackstone's statue begins
to melt, it's a neat bit of foreshadowing
for how he burns up in the finale.
Morticia pulling the flower head off a
red rose in front of Garrett Gates's grave is
a shout-out to the opening titles of the 60s
sitcom and the 90s movie where she cuts
the heads off the roses she's picking.
And there was another hat-tip to that
movie when we discover via the yearbook,
that Morticia attended Nevermore in 1991, the
same year The Addams Family movie was released.
On her way to Nevermore, if you pause, you can see
the suitably-named Addams family license plate,
which also reveals they live in New Jersey, a
homage to Charles Addams, who drew the original
cartoons, and was born in the Garden State.
After Gomez is arrested for murder, he has to
change into prison uniform, which has the number
171912 on it, an easter egg to the date and year
that Charles Addams was born;
January 7th, 1912.
Wednesday wears her trademark black dress and
white collar from her previous incarnations.
However, at Nevermore she has to wear a
school uniform but only ever dresses in
black and white, unlike everyone else.
And by the end, as she prepares to leave
Nevermore, she's back in her signature outfit.
Now, Addams Family fans won't have missed the
painting of Itt in the basement of the Nightshades
Society, however, if you pause here and zoom in,
we discover his full name was Ignatius
Itt and he was known as "Supreme Shade".
Although Ignatius Itt is no longer alive,
the way the show focuses on this painting
feels like a hint that we might see one
of his descendants appear in Season 2.
Principal Weem's costume was
influenced by Tippie Hedren's look
in Hitchcock's classic movie The Birds.
And you can see this especially in her
overall appearance, including her
hairstyle, at the Harvest Festival.
It's particularly appropriate given the
overwhelming raven imagery at Nevermore,
the bird on the Principal's desk, and
also the fact that Wednesday's dark,
foreboding visions place her at the Raven
end of the spectrum of psychic abilities.
You're a Raven.
Your visions are more potent, more powerful.
All this avian imagery, including the Rave'n
dance, and the name of the school itself is
also a huge shout-out to Edgar Allen Poe's
famous poem, The Raven, whose talking bird
repeatedly says the word 'Nevermore'.
Now, given the homage already to Hitchcock,
I think Wednesday's ever-so-slight smile
at the very end of the first episode
is a nod to Norman Bates's infamous
little smile at the end of Psycho.
When Tyler sets up a movie night date
with Wednesday in Crackstone's Crypt
and he puts on Legally Blonde, you can see
her wincing in discomfort from the movie.
Tyler probably knew she wouldn't like
it, so this could be a subtle red flag
and clue that his intentions towards her
aren't good as we discover by the end.
And I also think the moment is a little call-back
to Addams Family Values when Gary and Becky force
Wednesday, Pugsley and Joel to watch Disney
movies to try and force them to be happy.
The Little Mermaid.
Stop it.
He's only a child.
So, I already covered a lot of
the clues about why Miss Thornhill would turn
out to be the secret villain in my "Clues You
Missed" video, but what I didn't mention was
the one where Thornhill says to the mayor…
You're always tucked into that little back
booth when I come for my daily matcha latte.
… but then when she meets Tyler at the Rave'N,
he says she comes in every day for a cappuccino…
Double-cap, no foam, two
pumps of sugar-free vanilla.
…and her reply telegraphs the
fact she's up to something.
It's a small town.
It's hard to keep secrets.
When Wednesday goes to see her therapist, the
creators of the new show, Miles Millar and Alfred
Gough, get a shout-out as real estate agents.
And the two names below, Tommy Harper and
Natalie Testa, are producers on series.
The season ends on a big cliffhanger where
Wednesday discovers she has
a new threat to contend with,
but I'm really wondering how her stalker got
her cellphone number in the first place.
One possibility is that, as Xavier's got
her number already, someone installed some
malware on his phone and now this hacker could
even spy on conversations between the pair.
But if Xavier had installed
NordVPN, the sponsor of this video,
that threat would have been easily neutralised.
Thanks to its advanced threat protection features,
Nord is a lot more than just a VPN.
If you accidentally stumble across a
shady site or phishing link that downloads
a virus to your device, Nord will delete
the malicious software immediately.
And if you're using public Wi-Fi,
like in a coffee shop, you're especially at risk
from snoopers who can break into your connection
and access any personal data being transmitted.
So using a quality VPN like Nord on your mobile
devices will make sure you're
protected against these threats.
At home, Nord will also
keep your browsing private,
by preventing your internet service provider
from tracking what websites you're visiting.
Nord will also block those annoying
and intrusive ads, making your online
experience a lot cleaner, safer, and enjoyable.
For a limited time, all our viewers can grab
an exclusive offer on a 2-year plan with a huge
discount, plus 4 bonus months completely free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/FLICKS or go to the link
in the video description to get the offer.
Or use coupon code FLICKS when you check out.
There were some more great details and clues
hidden in Season 1 to the big villain
twist like the Frankenstein book Miss
Thornhill gave Wednesday and her deadly
carnivore plants which I talk a lot more
about in my other Wednesday video.
You can tap here to watch that,
plus there's a link in the video description.
So, what was your favourite moment in Wednesday?
And do you have any predictions
for what could happen in Season 2.
Let me know your thoughts and
theories in the comments below.
And if you enjoyed this video do leave
a thumbs-up, I really appreciate it.
Thanks for enjoying Wednesday
with me and hope you have a
marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!